starting shortly an author panel on
religion and the politics of faith will
be moderated by Jonathan Kirsch author
of the history of the end of the world
now feature author Reza Aslan Chris
Hedges and Jack miles a live coverage of
the LA Times Festival of Books good
morning everyone
although you've already been sharply
admonished I've been told that it's
critically important that I admonish you
further signings there is a book signing
following this session book signing for
this panel is located at the North
signing area line D this area is noted
on the festival map in the center of the
event program personal taping of
sessions is not allowed food or drinks
are not allowed in the session rooms and
as you've heard already please turn off
all cell phones and pagers for the
duration of this session I am going to
introduce our panelists I will then pose
some questions to them and engage them
in conversation and towards the end of
our session we'll open the mics and
invite you to ask your questions Jack
miles on my right is a distinguished
professor of English and religious
studies University of California Irvine
newly appointed in that position senior
fellow for Religious Affairs with the
Pacific Council on international policy
a MacArthur Fellow and currently scholar
in residence at the getty research
institute he's a scholar and a writer
whose work has appeared in the Atlantic
the New York Times Washington Post Los
Angeles Times The Boston Globe and many
other publications his book God a
biography won a Pulitzer Prize in 1996
and has been translated into 16
languages over a period of nearly 20
years ending in 1995 Myles was
successively an editor at doubleday
executive editor at the University of
California Press literary editor at the
Los Angeles Times and
a member of The Times editorial board
riding on politics and culture he's the
general editor of the forthcoming Norton
Anthology of world religions he's also
the author of Christ a crisis in the
life of God and I'm happy and always
grateful to be able to acknowledge him
as a friend and a mentor one of many
writers for whom he has served
graciously and generously in that role
Chris Hedges is a graduate of the
Harvard Divinity School and has served
as a correspondent for two decades most
of them for the New York Times reporting
from Central America at the height of
the fighting in El Salvador Guatemala
and Nicaragua in the early 80s as well
as the Middle East Africa and the
Balkans hedges was part of the New York
Times team that won the 2002 Pulitzer
Prize for reporting on global terrorism
he also won the 2002 Amnesty
International global Award for Human
Rights journalism he has taught at
Columbia Princeton and NYU and he is
currently a Lannon literary fellow and a
senior fellow at the nation Institute
hedges writes for numerous publications
including foreign affairs Harper's
Mother Jones in the New York Review of
Books he is the author of war is a force
that gives us meaning what every person
should know about war and losing Moses
on the freeway the Ten Commandments in
America
his current book is American fascists
the Christian Right and the war on
America Reza Aslan is a regular
commentator for NPR's marketplace and
Middle East analyst for CBS News he has
written for the Los Angeles Times The
New York Times Slate The Boston Globe
the Washington Post The Guardian Chicago
Tribune the nation and others and has
appeared on Meet the Press hardball The
Daily Show Real Time with Bill Maher
Meyer The Colbert Report
Anderson Cooper and Nightline his first
book no god but God the origins
evolution and future of Islam has been
translated into 1/2 half a dozen
languages and was shortlisted for the
Guardian UK first book award and
nominated for a pen USA award for
research nonfiction born in Iran he now
lives in Santa Monica where he is a
research associate
the University of Southern California's
Center on public diplomacy his next book
how to win a cosmic war why we're losing
the war on terror will be published by
Random House in the fall of 2008 and
just so as not to lose out on the
opportunity for self-promotion I am the
author most recently of history of the
end of the world how the most
controversial book in the Bible changed
the course of Western civilization thank
you as I was preparing for this
wonderful exciting stimulating panel I
read in the Los Angeles Times as I
suppose you did as well about some
aspects of religion and politics in our
own culture in our own environment I
read that the United States Department
of Veteran Affairs has approved the
Wiccan Pentacles as an approved emblem
of the leaf on the graves of soldiers
who have lost their lives in Iraq and
this is along with such religions as
eckankar Sufism reoriented and say H Oni
a of religion I never heard of before
and I offered that as a as a kind of
exhibit a of the open-mindedness of
towards religion in American politics
we've also read I think such a
thoroughly American story about the
Minneapolis Community and Technical
College which has announced its
intention to install facilities for the
Muslim ritual of foot washing after
students had been forced to engage in
that ritual in waist-high sinks and in a
in a very American gesture they first
made a field trip to a community college
in Michigan to inspect the ritual foot
baths that had been installed in that
facility these are of course gestures of
tolerance and open-mindedness that I
think we have come to expect and value
and appreciate in our own culture but we
also read in recent weeks about an
incident that took
on April 22nd in Iraq if there was not
enough heartbreak and horror coming out
of that country there's an incident in
with in which 23 people members of a
faith called Yazeed ISM were seized
arrested and shot in the Mosul province
of Iraq because of their membership in
this faith presumably the the pretext
for this atrocity was that at an earlier
date a member of the Yazidi community
having fallen in love with a Muslim and
converted to Islam was stoned to death
by her own community as a punishment for
apostasy and I went into the books to
find out a little bit about Yasin ISM
which I knew nothing about one of the
the secondary benefits of this horror in
Iraq is that we've learned a good deal
as a nation about the difference between
Shiite Islam and Sunni Islam but there
are many other religions in Iraq and I
found out that Yas it ism as small and
obscure as it is is in fact one small
and obscure branch of another small and
obscure religion that has two other
branches it's called the Asda nism the
other branches are Aleph ISM and yaar
Sunnism they're primarily ethnic Kurds
it's a synchronistic religion drawing on
Sufi traditions of Islam from Islam
drawing on Christian and Jewish
iconography and incorporating far older
Persian religious ideas it is that
contrast that I think we will be
confronting today
the contrast between an attitude towards
religion that allows and appreciates
diversity and an attitude towards
religion that leads to violence I'm
going to begin by allowing us all to
hear the words of our individual
panelists and then inviting each one to
comment on the themes raised in the in
the quotation the first reading I'm
going to give very briefly is from an
essay by Jack Myles the missionary
moment Christian America
in the world war of ideas where Jack
writes in his second inaugural address
President Bush spoke of freedom rather
than of Christianity and yet the
perception is more widespread now than
ever ever both at home and abroad that
the United States is in the throes of a
Christian revival fully capable of
shaping the decisions of the American
government as directly as it sought to
recently to do in the case of Terry
Schiavo I submit that much against the
grain of that revival what effective
diplomacy effective international
proselytization requires that this
juncture is minimally a forthright
disassociation of American polity from
Christian evangelism and beyond that a
reassertion both at home and abroad of
the religious neutrality of the American
Constitution what was done at the time
of the Treaty of Tripoli must be done
again and Jack I'll invite you to
illuminate us on the Treaty of Tripoli
and to apply that to the steps that
you're calling on us to take today it is
interesting to recall that the first
foreign war that the United States ever
engaged in was a war with a Muslim power
it was the war that was undertaken with
against the Barbary pirates that's what
we hear in the marine hymn from the
halls of Montezuma to the shores of
Tripoli Tripoli was a city-state
that preyed on shipping and enhanced its
income by holding captives for ransom
the United States chose to stop paying
the ransom and try to halt this practice
by by military action the outcome was
actually rather indecisive the
skirmishing went on for quite a while
but it was ended with a treaty and in
this treaty one Clause states that
religion shall never be a cause of
enmity between Tripoli and the United
States because the United States is and
I quote in
no way founded upon the Christian
religion now this this treaty was very
thoroughly debated clause by clause in
Congress some of our foreign treaties
are simply ratified and I kind of up and
down vote they aren't closely examined
by Congress but this one was very
closely examined and then unanimously
passed just to say therefore that the
United States is not found founded upon
the Christian religion is not against
the American grain it is thoroughly in
the American grain the Constitution in
its in First Amendment to the
Constitution states that Congress will
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion and even before the First
Amendment article 4 states that there
will in this country be no religious
test for public office so an atheist can
hold office a member of any given
religion may hold office the question
will never be asked what is your
religion before that you can duly stand
for election to an office or be
appointed to one by someone who has been
elected because the perception abroad is
now so widespread that America has left
its commitment to this religious
neutrality behind I do believe that a
part of our national recovery from this
very difficult moment ought to be a
reassertion of who we have always been
and a statement that we are that again
in case any questions have arisen in
anyone's mind on that point obviously
questions have indeed arisen on that
point we could never persuade American
society to be less Christian than it is
and it's not the responsibility of our
government to do anything of the sort
but a distinction has always existed
here between the state and the society
America does not have an established
religion it does have an established way
of dealing with religion and
an established way of dealing with
religion is religious neutrality thank
you jack I'm gonna read great briefly
from Reza Aslan very compelling book
there is no god but God in the half
century since the end of colonialism and
the founding of the Islamic state Islam
has been invoked to legitimize and to
overturn governments to promote
Republican republicanism and defend
authoritarianism
to justify monarchies autocracies
oligarchies and theocracies and to
promote terrorism factionalism and
hostility the question remains can Islam
now be used to establish a genuinely
liberal democracy in the Middle East can
a modern Islamic state reconcile reason
and revelation to create a Democratic
Society based on the ethical ideals
established by the Prophet Muhammad in
Medina nearly 15 centuries ago not only
can it do so it must indeed it already
is doing so throughout parts of the
Muslim world and Reza what I would
invite you to do is to address that
general comment to the the situation
that we see today in Iraq and the
timetable that's on that has been
proposed is there any hope that a
liberal democracy in Iraq can be
achieved within the patience of the
American electorate yeah that's a good
question but first of all I feel like
I'm at the kids table here is it just me
I just maybe it's the chair Chris is
that the microphones are about at nose
levels yeah talk through your nose
you'll be heard I already feel somewhat
an inadequate US sitting at this table
so I think I did the chair on purpose
well I think look it's important to to
make a distinction here when we're
talking about these terms that are
tossed around so often and and often
undefined like Islamic democracy when
when someone refers to this idea of
Islamic democracy we're not talking
about a theö democracy we're talking
about a modern constitutional state
dedicated to all of
the principles the elements that make a
democracy and that's important I mean
there's no such thing as democracy there
are elements that when put together
create a democratic system like popular
sovereignty in the separation of powers
and constitutionalism the rule of law
ethnic and religious pluralism
dedication to human rights you put all
of those things or it's like it's like a
recipe and those are all the ingredients
and you toss them into a cauldron and
what you have is a delicious soup of
democracy so then the question is you
can't take any of these elements out
otherwise the entire the recipe
collapses but can you then put some kind
of religiously inspired moral foundation
into that mix well not only can you but
we do all the time I think jack is
absolutely correct that this country
wasn't founded on as a Christian nation
as it is often referred to but
nevertheless the ideologies the customs
the mores the national traditions of
this country are deeply deeply Christian
and not just Christian but Protestant
and that's neither necessarily a bad
thing nor is it I mean in some ways it's
kind of inevitable particularly in a
Democratic Society
if you leave live in a country that says
that you know the the ideas the values
the mores of the majority are going to
you know have a certain amount of
influence influence that is in some ways
equivalent to the numbers of the
proportion of those people then you
really have no choice if you want to
live in a democratic society but to have
that kind of influence in in the state
we're live in a country or according to
Newsweek 78% of Americans call
themselves Christian so it's only
natural that in the discussions about
our laws our customs our values our very
identities as Americans Christianity is
going to play a very large part in a
country like Iraq which is ninety-six
percent Muslim when it comes time to
create some sense of popular sovereignty
some eye
eeeh that the values of the individuals
in society are going to be reflected in
in the values and customs and even laws
of the state as long as those laws don't
violate that those elements that have to
be in that cauldron in order for it to
be called the Democratic Society then
that it's not necessarily there's
certainly room for for problems and
there's certainly room for fanaticism as
we see even in this country but in some
ways to me it seems like a few tall
enterprise to say that we need to remove
religion from from the public realm and
that we need to strip the state from its
any kind of religious ideas or influence
that's a great idea I wish it were
possible but it's not certainly not in a
democratic society if you want to live
in a society in which under the guise of
democracy religion is forcefully removed
from the public realm move to Turkey but
if you want to live in a society based
not necessarily upon secularism but upon
pluralism then you sort of have to be
willing to deal with the consequences of
that and the consequences of that are
that as long as again it doesn't violate
the laws it doesn't violate the mandates
that are necessary and it to be called a
democracy you're going to have people
like you know Tom DeLay and and Tom
Tancredo and James Inhofe who are going
to be motivated by their religious faith
is it a problem yes is it avoidable I
don't think so thank you
I'm gonna next read from Chris Hedges
book American fascism and I wanted to
play a little bit of a thought
experiment with you by leaving out the
the subject of the sentence that I'm
going to read or the section although I
think that this audience is familiar
enough with Chris's book that they'll
know already but I would invite you to
keep in mind militant Islam as you hear
these words from American fascism Chris
is writing about what he calls a
frightening political mass movement with
many similarities to other mass
movements from fascism to communism to
ethnic nationalist parties in the former
Yugoslavia this movement shares with
these movements an inability to cope
with ambiguity doubt and uncertainty it
creates its own truth it embraces a
world of miracles and signs and removes
followers from a rational reality based
world it condemns self-criticism and
debate as apostasy the believers in this
movement hedges rights have abandoned
their trust and belief in a world of
science law and rationality they ask you
personal choice and freedom they have
replaced the world that has failed them
with a new glorious world filled with
prophets and mystical signs the movement
that Chris describes in his words places
a premium on action and finds its final
aesthetic in war and apocalyptic
violence and yet of course Chris is not
writing about militant Islam he's
writing about what he calls radical
Christian dominionists who are
manipulating Christianity and millions
of sincere believers and slowly
dismantling democratic institutions to
establish a religious tyranny the
springboard to an American fascism do
you feel in any sense you may be
overstating this case
No
this isn't theoretical for me I come out
of 20 years of covering disintegrating
societies such as the former Yugoslavia
I've spent seven years in the Middle
East as an Arabic speaker much of that
time with groups like Hamas you know
this fusion of Christian language and
Christian iconography with the language
and iconography of American nationalism
is toxic and dangerous and it bears it
is a radical mutation or radical break
from what we have seen in American
society that made up fundamentalism or
fundamentalist movements fundamentalists
always called on believers to remove
themselves from the contaminants of
secular society to shun political
involvement traditional evangelicals
such as Billy Graham always warned
followers about getting too close to
political power he himself was used and
burned by Richard Nixon when he came to
Nixon's defense during the Watergate
scandal a lesson he never forgot but we
see new now is something that we have
not seen in American history with all of
the religious revivals going back to
1740 and the Great Awakening
it is a drive to take secular power and
that's new and like all totalitarian
movements it plays off of profound
personal and economic despair we live in
a country where the top 1% has now
amassed more wealth than the bottom 90%
combined this figure alone should
frighten everyone in this room who cares
about democracy going all the way back
to the to the writers of Plutarch and
Thucydides those who wrote about the the
sustenance and nurturing of Athenian
democracy it was understood that gross
disparities and inequities within a
society make it impossible to sustain
the democratic state there are now less
manufacturing jobs in this country than
at any time 9% then at any time since
the Industrial Revolution and these jobs
have not been replaced with jobs that
offer salaries that equal their salaries
are 1/3 less than what people were
making in
still steel mills 20 years ago without
benefits without health insurance with a
slashing of state and federal assistance
programs it's not overly dramatic to say
that there are whole pockets of the
United States that now to resemble the
developing world and if you if you go
back and read Hannah Aaron or Karl
Popper or Fritz Stearns the politics of
cultural despair you understand that the
engine of despotic movements is this
despair because it thrusts people into
the arms of demagogues you know the war
in Yugoslavia was not caused by ancient
ethnic hatreds despite what robert
kaplan wrote it was caused by the
economic collapse of Yugoslavia and if
we don't blunt the rise of the American
oligarchy on the corporate state we're
not going to blunt this movement which
is I believe the most dangerous mass
movement in American history it is a
movement that removes people from a
reality based world it turned it throws
them into the arms of people who
promised them a world of magic of
miracles that Jesus will not only walk
with them and has a divine plan for them
and take care of them but ultimately
make them prosperous and wealthy that's
where the term the gospel of prosperity
comes from and I think for those of us
who grew up you know in in a religious
tradition my father was a Presbyterian
minister as you heard I graduated from
seminary oh and and are biblically
literate we have a tremendous window
into what the real goals of this
movement are and how they have distorted
misused and often fabricated sections of
the Bible in order to embrace a theology
which i think is properly called
a theology of despair rather than a
theology of hope and by the term
theology of despair it is because the
most glorious moment for these believers
comes in that cataclysmic apocalyptic
violence that use of violence is a
massive cleansing agent which is of
course always part of totalitarian
movements when believers in this bizarre
spiritual Darwinism will be lifted up
into heaven and the rest of us will be
extent
English in horrifying I think it's not
an extreme word to use pornographic
visions of violence that are peddled by
this movement in the Left Behind series
and others and I think that if we as a
society do not begin to confront the
corporate state and the oligarchic state
if if we don't recognize that we as a
society have turned our backs on tens of
millions of Americans betrayed them I'm
talking about both political parties
NAFTA was the gift of a democratic
administration as was the throwing of 1
million people off of US welfare rolls
if we don't begin to reincorporate these
people to reinforce and a society then I
think our democracy is doomed
Chris I'd like to follow up with you in
particular and then I'm going to quit
ask you to answer briefly and then we'll
move on to a more general question for
all the panelists in my own book on
Revelation I also noted that revelation
and the apocalyptic fantasy is really
the proof text of the religious right
but it has also been read as a
liberation theology text by Catholic
theologians Philip Berrigan in
particular invoked revelation and saw
within it a liberating and egalitarian
message and not just this punishing
message of the right wing and then
another commentator on Revelation
compared it to Martin Luther King Jr's
letter from a Birmingham jail and this
reminds me that there is a segment of
evangelical Christianity in the black
churches of America that has always been
the location of a progressive political
agenda and continues to be do you think
that this is really specific Aliyah
Christian religious problem or is there
not a an aspect of the Christian
religious community that is in itself
politically progressive and maybe even
politically radical well I mean as you
know better than I the book of
Revelation is a very controversial book
Martin Luther Martin Luther when he when
he made the German edition of the Bible
relegated it to an appendix and there's
no question that that you know there are
passages within the Hebrew Bible in the
Greek Bible that are morally
indefensible I mean the Gospel of John
is rapidly anti-semitic you know God
blesses ACK whole acts of genocide in
the Hebrew Bible and I think that that
you know there is enough within the
Bible for any bigot or tyrant or anybody
who wants to justify cruelty and
exclusion to sanctify it you know that
the slave owners did it and you know
Reinhold Niebuhr had that great line you
know that the the religion is a is a
good thing for good people and a bad
thing for bad people unfortunately this
radical
Christian right these are bad people and
I think that the the sort of liberal
Church can often sort of gloss over and
has not come to grips with the fact that
you're right the book of Revelation
although it of course I think if you're
you know if you're oppressed I mean you
know just as many in the
african-american community especially
during the time of slavery read in
Exodus you know Moses flight from
Pharaoh and Egypt in a very different
way than the slave owners I mean it
often depends you know I'll tell you a
little story as having grown up in the
church and graduated from seminary I
often times I found reporting especially
in in areas of tremendous conflict and
among tremendous human suffering that
there were passages of the Bible that
from my position of privilege I didn't
understand and I was in a refugee camp
in Honduras for people who had fled the
war in El Salvador I covered the war
there and they were decorating the camp
it was in January and it was they were
about to celebrate the flight of of Mary
Joseph and the infant Jesus towards
Egypt when Herod comes in in the night
that he kills the slaughter of the
innocents and I asked one of the
refugees who was probably an illiterate
campesino why this was such an important
day and he said because that's the day
Jesus became a refugee and I think that
the liberation theologians are on to
something in the sense that and
especially with the Hebrew Bible and and
I think arguably you know most of the
Christian Bible these were written by
groups that were oppressed and I think
that that somehow not for those of us
who come from zones of privilege not to
be able to stand in that position of
oppression makes us unable to understand
biblical stories such as that one that I
had heard my father read every year in
church since before I could read I
wanted to dig into a practical question
I'm gonna invite each of panelists to
comment and I'll start with Jack and
move to the left I when I brought up the
the Muslim foot bath in Minneapolis
I'd meant it by way of praise I I think
it shows a decent impulse to accommodate
and respect religious diversity and even
to implement it and yet the reality is
if you are Jewish and you want to wear a
skullcap there are many schools public
schools that will exclude you and thus
you will have to go to an Orthodox
Jewish day school if you want to wear a
skullcap I see that as as the kind of
where the rubber meets the road in terms
of a democracy dealing with religious
extremism do you accommodate the
fundamentalist believer so that that
believer stays within the mainstream so
that the Islamic woman who wears a
headscarf can attend the public school
and does not have to go to the
environment of a Lama klonda Mentalist
school or do you enforce this absolute
religious neutrality at the risk of
accentuating this impulse towards
isolation and extremism is there any
solution to this problem in
accommodating diversity in my opening
remarks I talked about the difference
between religion as established by the
state and religion as accommodated in
the society I would say that the example
that you bring up Jonathan Falls pretty
well into the category of accommodation
within the society the president of that
that College was attempting to protect
his school against possible lawsuits
brought about by somebody slipping and
falling on a wet bathroom floor having
tried to wash her her foot in in a basin
that was four feet off the ground
another American moment what an American
moment exactly exactly everything is
driven by the flight from possible
lawsuits and but you know in a you know
in a broader sense you know what life is
like in American schools people come in
with us with one spike of orange hair
down the middle of their skull and a big
deal you know somebody else is wearing a
veil
somebody else has a Star of David it's
the American soup and we we take it in
our stride and it has as one of its very
beneficial side effects that people get
used to being in this country together
Toleration at the macro level begins
with such micro encounters I recall a
story told by James Carroll who is a
former a priest who lives in Boston a
columnist there and an author of a
number of books he was talking about how
how it came about that the Roman
Catholic Church issued its declaration
on relations with the Jews you know
apologizing for Christian least Catholic
anti-semitism over so many centuries it
began with a mixed marriage in the
Cardinals family he had and I think it
was his sister who had married a Jew or
maybe said the way around at any rate
food comes into the picture somewhere
you know it had many happy happy meals
in this Jewish household and it bothered
him that there was this official enmity
well
encounters of that sort often begin in
school relations and classmate relations
and the more a kind of casual toleration
of that sort can can be allowed the less
likely it is that entrenched divisions
will be will be devil our our life later
on in that connection I it occurs to me
to to mention a very American move that
the Muslim Public Affairs Council
recently made issuing a set of
guidelines for relations between Sunnis
and Shias things that a polite Shia
ought not to say about Sunnis in a
polite Sony ought not to say about Shia
this is not this is all on the near side
of any kind of government establishment
of religion it's a kind of good manners
but it was it seemed to me the arrival
of a kind of pluralism within the
American Muslim
community and one of the reasons why I
believe the American Muslim community
will eventually have a very prophetic
role to play in in world Islam Chris
well I mean this sort of presupposes
that there's something good about the
mainstream I having about the mainstream
not much they having lived 20 years
outside the United States I mean these
are questions that you just don't ask I
mean it's you know that kind of it's it
it is a really attempt you know by
enforcing any kind of code like that to
destroy one's individuality one's
tradition you know and we as a country
did a pretty good job of doing that to
African Americans you know to the point
that we even took away their names and I
think it's something that we should be
particularly sensitive to you know the
point is to get the kids into a
classroom and hand them Thoreau's Walden
you know the point is to get them to
think it really doesn't matter what they
wear what really radical audience yeah
screw the mainstream no I'm totally with
you I would the thing is is that yet
Chris and I went to the same seminary
and this is what they teach you there
I'm not kidding
I think look this question about you
know assimilation versus isolation all
you have to do is see you know what the
rest of the world is doing Europe does
not have a conception of accommodating
or assimilating these kinds of religious
ideologies into the larger society and
they are having a terrible time of it
you know the kinds of radicalization
that we see in the UK and in France and
which simply do not exist in the United
States are more than just you know
economic factors yes it's true in the
case of the Muslim community here in the
u.s. they're very well integrated
they're you know very wealthy they're
very much a part of every sector of
society but it's more than that I think
that the reason that there is such
accommodation that there is such simple
assimilation and integration here in the
United States whether you're a Jew or a
Muslim or Hindu or Sikh or whatever is
that we do have an conception here that
religion does have some role to play in
the public realm maybe it's too great a
role no question and maybe it has far
too much influence in in our laws and
and certainly in our foreign policy but
we understand that faith is is is not
something that should be shunned from
from the the public realm and I think
that that creates a level of comfort
particularly for immigrant communities
and people of other faiths besides you
know Christianity and Judaism that makes
them much more likely to not just
assimilate into culture but also to
moderate their own religious viewpoints
in their and their own ideas you know
when I travel through the the Middle
East especially you know it's amazing
how often you hear death to America
death to America can I get a visa
because there is there is this
recognition and I'm not kidding when I
say this that there is no country on
this earth that gives Muslims the rights
and the freedoms and the privileges to
worship their religion however they see
fit in the United States they may hate
our government but they would do
anything to have our lives so again I
think you have to you have to kind of
have this notion okay if if political
participation is a cure for religious
radicalism it's a way of moderating
religious extremism and if that's true
in Lebanon and it's true in Palestine
then it's got to be true here in America
too whether we like it or not no matter
how uncomfortable it makes us there is a
real fear of this kind of radical
particularly Christian evangelism that
that has so thoroughly snaked its way
into to the highest levels of the
government but nevertheless you know to
to talk about rooting that out it can be
somewhat dangerous because we have to be
very careful not to violate those ideas
of freedom the the conceptions
particularly of the way we view faith
and religion in this country and the
freedom of faith and religion in this
country we have to be careful not to
violate those those ideas and sometimes
to not violate them we sometimes have to
put up with some distasteful
consequences so again I I know I feel
like I've begun the guide dinner in here
back and forth but but nonetheless I
know that this is this is not just
theory and I don't want to make it sound
as though I'm just speaking
theoretically but it is very important
for us in in recognizing the alarm and
the dangers of this kind of religious
radicalism to also understand that in
most cases the best cure for religious
radicalism is assimilation is
integration is is participation so that
the people themselves can choose to to
adopt or ignore these these ideas these
these values these traditions and
because this is such as
group I think that's sort of inevitable
the rejection of those ideas is almost
inevitable let me follow up with
resident Cressida Ellen but you make
your comment last night Lawrence right
one book prize for the looming tower a
really compelling book about Al Qaeda
and he makes the point and I'm very
mindful of it when I suggest that
somehow allowing people to wear head
scarves and wash their feet in public
schools will solve the problem of
Islamic violence I'm very mindful of the
fact that the men who piloted the planes
into the World Trade Center were in fact
very cosmopolitan highly educated they
had lived in America it didn't do
anything to moderate their idea about
Islam in fact it made them into
extremists and I'm wondering Reza can
shed any light on that phenomenon that
when the fundamentalist comes to the
west in some cases he returns even more
violently fundamental than when he
arrived yeah well I think first of all
we have to assume this notion that
somehow all religious Islamic extremists
have the same ideas or ideologies or or
grievances or or tactics or agendas it's
simply not the case al Qaeda and the
larger jihadist movement that they
represent and by jihadism I'm referring
to the trans nationalist movement of
militant Islamic Puritanism Arab Islamic
Puritanism that al-qaeda is is such a
such a you know and to go part of but
there is a world of difference between
Al Qaeda and Hamas or Hezbollah or the
Kashmiri militants or or you know even
the insurgency in in Iraq and so you
know we we talk all the time about well
you know the key to solving terrorism is
social and economic development that's
the key to solving terrorism in Lebanon
it's the key to solving terrorism in
Palestine but it has no effect on
jihadism whatsoever because the
jihadists want nothing they have no
political agenda whatsoever their
nominal goals are absurd even to them
they're not going to recreate the
caliphate they have no interest in
really know that these are impossible
Bush talks more about their goals than
they talk
about their goals so of course as a
movement that is that is using that's
really a social movement more than
anything else and that is using these
symbols of of jihad to create not just a
collective identity but to spur
collective action of course it's going
to be made up of the best and brightest
in the same way that the radical
anti-globalization movements are the
best and the brightest are middle-class
kids throwing firebombs not poor kids so
that's not unusual it's not surprising
but that's not we're not talking about
jihadism jihadism wants nothing they
have no goals they have to be rooted out
they have to be destroyed simple but for
the vast majority of the other so-called
Islamic radical or Islamic extremist
movements it is very important to not
just address those grievances but to
bring them into the fold in order to
moderate their tendencies because they
want something if you want something you
can be talked to Chris I just want it
and they asked all the panel's to keep
their comments yeah cuz we're running at
it just two quick issues one on the fact
that middle-class people like you know
Mohammed Atta and others are involved
the problem with going into a culture
like the American culture or the
European culture is that it often and
many of these jihadists were actually
born in the banlieues you know outside
of lyon paris and other places is that
they struggle with a terrible identity
crisis they don't fit into american or
european society and they don't fit in
at home at all and they become ripe for
manipulation by the demagogues who make
up this movement secondly on the issue
of religious involvement in the u.s. in
within government you know we live in a
country the last sort of ratings that
were done by the christian coalition the
Eagle Forum the three most in and a
Family Resource Council the three most
powerful Christian Right advocacy groups
in Washington gave forty five senators
186 members of the House of
Representatives between an 80 to 100
percent approval rating and this
administration is handed over billions
of US taxpayer dollars to these groups
now obviously I don't have any problem
with
you're either an individuals or a groups
religious orientation but I have a
tremendous problem with groups that
discriminate based on sexual orientation
religious belief and of course are using
federal money to proselytize that's
unacceptable under the Constitution
that's a violation
I just want to preview the fact that I'm
going to pose one more question I'm
gonna directed to Jack and invite the
panelists to chime in and then I'm gonna
go to the mic so if you are gonna ask a
question you can prepare it now mumaith
the point that at an earlier stage of
American history at least officially we
were not declared not to be a Christian
government and I might add Martin Luther
put revelation in the appendix Thomas
Jefferson excised it from the Jefferson
Bible he said revelation was merely the
ravings of a maniac so we have a good
set of traditions and precedents for
avoiding these religious imprints on
public policy and yet just this last
week or so the United States Supreme
Court enacted as a matter of law a
position on abortion which is a
theologically based position our
government has a position on stem cell
research which is a theologically based
position these are two what I would
regard as crucial impingements on
personal liberty and even personal
health that spring out of this religious
idea that has seized the American
political entity and in that sense I'm
asking Jack do you believe that this
threat of dismantling democratic
institutions to establish religious
tyranny that Kris is warning us against
in in many ways has already happened I
don't think it's already happened
because of the Supreme Court decision or
the stem-cell research position our
society would be coming to some kind of
determination along those lines and and
there would be some kind of morality
with regard to human life operative in
any case I wouldn't expect even if all a
religious input were eliminated that
there would be unanimity
a point like that I would expect
difference what is more the troubling to
me and I believe also to Chris is the
penetration of a religious ideology
that's in love with death that is I'm
more concerned about a penetration of
religious ideology into the military
than I am into anything that takes place
in the full light of day on the Supreme
Court that's that that troubles me more
I would also I think be concerned with
lower level appointments that matter in
the State Department in the in the
Justice Department I also want to
underscore by my agreement with with
Chris that there is a good deal of
despair abroad in our country but it is
not confined to the religious right much
less today to the Christian right David
Foster Wallace did a very impressive
article for the Atlantic on right-wing
talk radio and one of the conclusions he
drew was that both the hosts and the
audience's for these these programs are
filled with despair they regard the
country as as doomed though religion is
not prominent in their exchanges why
would they feel that way it's because of
that list of economic developments that
that he talked about and some social
developments that maybe are threatening
to some people as well those things
create a climate in in which a hunger to
somehow end it all can can't take over
the mind it's a kind of madness not a
religious only secular as well I'm gonna
invite questions from the audience this
is for any any of the panelists would
like to comment we've heard we've heard
this afternoon that 78% of Americans
consider themselves Christians we also
see statistics suggesting that 93% of
the National Academy of Sciences do not
believe in a personal God we see a
growing number of scientists from Victor
Stegner Richard Dawkins Edward o Wilson
beginning to take on what they consider
the
problems of mythical thinking Karen
Armstrong is written at length about the
conflict between mythos and logos do we
live in an age in which the two are so
in conflict that they're irreconcilable
or is it possible for a belief system
based on mythical thinking to reconcile
itself in the scientific age well I
would just like to chime in by saying in
Karen's defense there are people who
will throw the baby out with the
bathwater they'll say there's nothing
redeeming about the religious
imagination and Karen is a writer who
celebrates the religious imagination and
I think that that's it's possible to
hold both thoughts in your mind at the
same time and I think that's certainly
true of Jack's work and Reza's as well
but I'll invite the other panelists I
would like to suggest that as an example
of a middle point thinker someone who is
an atheist himself but who regards
religion as a permit permanent fixture
in the human landscape and who explains
on scientific grounds why it is so and
will remain so is David Sloan Wilson I I
would commend his new book evolution for
everyone most especially and in that
book he talks also about departures from
what he calls factual realism with
ominous consequences for practical
realism that are of secular origin sir
yeah I wanted to thank all of the panels
for their contribution is this really
important discussion today and in
particular Eucharist and actually I'd
like to say just by way of introduction
I somebody who is a product of 16 years
of Catholic education and it did two
things to me it gave me the best
education at 12th century had to offer
and it it also spurred me on to become a
militant atheist and a communist and so
and I wanted to say you know one of the
things I you know your work on on this
the rise of this Christian fascist
movement I've also studied the work of
Bob Avakian the chairman of the
Revolutionary Communist Party he's done
some very penetrating given now sorry
can we get a question because there all
right you know we just the point is is
that you know he's done some very
penetrating analysis around religious
fundamentalism in this whole point that
you make and he makes about
this unity that's developed between the
Christian fascists and the political
regime you have a rapacious Empire
political agenda recreating the world
and on the other side you have and I
think this is not just a handful of
people race I think it's actually you
have an Islamic fundamentalist movement
that's growing up due to the the total
you know of people in the world okay
thank you for your watchin I really have
only minutes I know I know but you just
let somebody speak on for a long time
now I'm just asking you this question
where do you see hope because I
personally I think of baking talks about
a revolutionary okay let me let me just
let me answer quickly that there is an
alliance between the corporate interests
and this movement because if you your
job is taken from you outsource your
community disintegrates oh it's it's
very comforting to buy into the
mythology that once you get right with
Jesus you'll be taken care of and that's
why groups like Sam's Club and others
will actually put these Walmart will put
these chaplains within their
corporations because it does as Marx
understood acts as an opiate and you're
also Jack very right this radical
Christian group now controls over 50% of
chaplaincy appointments within the
military and the service academies and I
think that there's two things one we
have to look at them really as
functioning more as comma czars they're
making people loyal to an ideology not
the democratic state and okay look I'm
gonna go to this gentleman short
questions and answers please
I think the impact of the black church
has been underestimated in our
conversation and the reality that the
Christian Right modeled their political
methodology on the success of the black
church to achieve the civil rights
revolution and so I'd like to comment on
this bad people comment you made earlier
Pat Robertson and Jerry fault were bad
people before they became religious
figures yeah and that's really the the
despair is cultural yeah and the loss of
segregation and now in the immigration
debate it's the cultural much more than
economic disparity the people V you make
a very important point and you know this
movement tries to paint itself as the
heirs
the civil rights movement said when I
would attend rallies in Ohio like at
patriot pastors they'll put pictures of
Rosa Parks and Martin Luther King up
before they begin their rallies talking
about how they're the natural heirs
which of course they're not because the
figures like fall well for instance got
his rise with the attempts at
desegregation he you know he for 10 10
years all he did was preach bigotry and
exclusion from his pulpit and then a
wonderful sort of Stalinist move went
and had all of those sermons recalled we
only have a copy of one and it's raw raw
racism this movement comes directly out
of the John Birch Society which comes
out of the world anti-communist League
which goes right back to the Klan and
every chapter of the Klan had a chaplain
and that's the despair thank you how do
you see the future treatment of gay
lesbian and transgender people by this
new Christian evangelist government
because I've heard some far left-wing
fears of violence and relocation camps
and that a little I think that the most
important battle that we are fighting as
a society is against this effort by this
movement to strip American citizens of
their rights because of their sexual
gender and we have been walking
backwards on this issue the gay rights
movement is recoiling with almost no
assistance from anyone else if you are a
professional gay who lives in an urban
setting you know that there's a kind of
inward focus but if you're you know a
gay kid pumping gas out in Mississippi
and 17 life has become one of Terror and
you know just look at the statistics for
teenage suicides among gays no I you're
talking about Mel why are events like
actually being viable you know none of
these movements can succeed unless there
is a crisis for them to ride a period of
prolonged economic and economic collapse
another catastrophic terrorist attack a
series of environmental disasters just
as Milosevic needed to rise the collapse
of Yugoslavia khana me to power this
movement but should that happen and you
know the indicators aren't great out
there then you know going after the most
vulnerable segments of a society it's
what they did with the ballot measures
in two
thousand four with the eleven states
voted to ban gay marriage gay marriage
was already illegal in all of those
states except for Oregon 27 states
already a 1996 federal law defines
marriage as between a man and a woman it
is really about empowering a movement to
crush the most vulnerable and and when
they finish with those social deviants
they have a long list and that attack on
on gays and lesbians was part of the
march towards our door I just want to
talk about 30 seconds and less that
about the language that we even have
used here today that we use that the
language of militant Islam and we don't
talk about the militant Judaism or
fundamentalist Jews and when you talk
about this scarf the woman wearing a
scarf wanted to go to a fundamental
religious school rather than when when a
Christian person wants to go to a
Christian school and we don't use the
same language for Christians and Muslims
so therefore we painting the Muslims to
be a different people worse than the
rest of them you know that's one thing
we want to concern and my question was
you know how do how do we come about to
change this and have the tolerance to
come about well I mean look we have to
be very careful with our words no
question about it I mean if we if it is
true that we're engaged in an
ideological war well the greatest weapon
in an ideological war are your words
and so we have to be careful how we talk
particularly because we are embroiled in
a in a conflict with people who think
that they're fighting a cosmic war
between the forces of good and evil
between the sons of light and the sons
of darkness and that what's at stake is
they're very existential being there are
very identities we're talking about the
war in the exact same way and by doing
so we're essentially validating you know
their their viewpoint and that's
unwinnable we can't we can't win that
kind of war so we really do as Jack said
have to strip these conflicts of their
break was raised on this because you
know having lived in societies where I
watched them try and domesticate the
Nationalists in Yugoslavia any open
society that tolerates the intolerant
sieze tolerance disappear and the
tolerant along with them I I would also
like to add there in my notes and I
always try to make a point of it James
Charles cop is a man Christian
fundamentalist who murdered a doctor who
performed abortion out of Christian
fundamentalism Baruch Goldstein was an
American Jewish physician who took a
machine gun to the mosque at the cave of
patriarchs and murdered Muslims in the
act of prayer and so it is absolutely
the case that religious fundamentalism
is a poison that poisons the minds of
Christians Jews and Muslims it's not a
Muslim I'm gonna have to close you'll be
able to talk to the authors at the
signing booth I want to thank all of my
colleagues for joining us
Thanks